So we just saw how to graph using
a table of values or a T-chart.
Now let's talk about
graphing with intercepts.
And first, let's meet John and
his mom and dad.
And let's say that John borrows
money from his parents, in fact,
he borrows $200.
And he promises that he's
going to pay back $10 a week.
This is a classic case of needing math.
Let's use a variable to
represent how much money
John still owes his
parents at a given time.
In fact, let's use one of my favorites.
Let's say y represents how much
money John owes his parents.
Well, we can say that's
equal to 200-10x.
And here, x represents the number of
weeks that have gone by since John's
gotten the loan from his parents.
And this makes me think,
how much does John owe at week 0?
And how much does he owe at week 20?
And give your answers to these
questions here and here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]